[Musica]
da circa 30 anni come giornalista uso
l'informatica per fare il cacciatore di
bufale
vado a caccia di disinformazione di
leggende metropolitane di quelle che
oggi si chiamano molto spesso fake news
Noi oggi siamo circondati da questo
fenomeno molti di voi magari si stanno
chiedendo ma Attivissimo che cognome è
sarà per caso anche quella è una fake
news una bufala per prevenire questo
vostro dubbio naturalissimo io ho
portato una scansione del mio passaporto
mi chiamo veramente così le fake news
sono dappertutto Oggi siamo circondati
se ne parla tantissimo Come mai Cosa è
successo cosa è cambiato
fake news in realtà con altri nomi
esistono da sempre due esempi classici
di fake news tradizionali la donazione
di Costantino un documento documenti che
poi si è dimostrato essere un falso
storico oppure i protocolli dei Savi di
Sion usati per screditare gli ebrei
dalla polizia zarista all'inizio del
Novecento documenti che mostrano una
fabbricazione di notizie false dall'alto
abbiamo dei governi delle ideologie che
decidono di manipolare le nostre
opinioni La nostra percezione della
realtà
Ma esiste anche la disinformazione
esistono anche le fake news dal basso
sono quelle che condividiamo noi sono le
dicerie che sentiamo raccontate dagli
amici sono storie classiche addirittura
alcune che hanno 50 anni sulle spalle
come quella degli additivi cancerogeni
circolavano come ciclostile all'inizio
negli anni 70 oggi girano come PDF
allegati alle mail e il messaggio sui
social network oggi quindi abbiamo due
mondi di disinformazione che possiamo
mettere a confronto ma è successo
qualche cosa da questi casi classici da
questi casi storici dall'alto e dal
basso È arrivato un fenomeno nuovo
arrivato a una tecnologia che ha
cambiato completamente il mondo delle
fake news che ha spostato il confine di
questo mondo di fantasie di storie
strane che tutti condividiamo è arrivata
a internet ma soprattutto più che
internet sono arrivati i social network
social network hanno delle
caratteristiche molto particolari
È ovvio che quando è arrivata internet
quando sono arrivati i social network i
governi E le ideologie di tutti i generi
hanno deciso di sfruttare questo nuovo
territorio hanno deciso di estendere il
proprio confine di disinformazione
utilizzando questo nuovo canale per
raggiungere rapidamente in modo efficace
virale tantissime persone un esempio
classico Forse poco conosciuto e quello
dell'attività dei disinformazione di
origine russa A proposito del 5G molta
gente sente questi movimenti stop 5G non
sa che spesso queste produzioni di
disinformazione vengono finanziate da
movimenti di origine legata al governo
Russo quindi c'è qualcuno che decide di
manipolare la nostra visione di una
nuova tecnologia che potrebbe ridurre
l'impatto ambientale delle comunicazioni
e cerca di farcela perdere di lasciarla
da parte e di casi come questi Ce ne
sono tantissimi
ma c'è un altro fenomeno forse ancora
meno conosciuto che il meccanismo
all'interno dei social network noi tutti
usiamo i social network siamo
in contatto con i nostri amici
attraverso questo canale gratuito
apparentemente gratuito di comunicazione
quello che forse non è chiaro molti e
che ormai esiste una base di dati
scientifici che dimostrano un fenomeno
molto particolare
i social network Vivono di indignazione
sono nati per farci arrabbiare ci sono
ricerche scientifiche che dimostrano che
più i contenuti che noi vediamo sui
social network sono negativi ci fanno
arrabbiare stimolano l'odio verso
qualcuno o qualcosa più tempo noi
passiamo sui social network e questo è
prezioso per i social network perché più
tempo passiamo su questi ambienti più
siamo esposti alle loro pubblicità
e quindi più aumenta il loro fatturato
un recente esperimento ha documentato il
fatto che se si toglie dai social
network la negatività quindi i messaggi
di odio di tutti i generi la
frequentazione di quei social network
crolla di circa un quarto quindi abbiamo
dei dati che dimostrano che è importante
per i social network e i social network
lo sanno creare negatività
questo meccanismo si basa su un processo
particolare che è stato illustrato
all'interno
da Francis Hogan ex data Scientist di
Facebook che ha documentato come
all'interno l'organizzazione sa
benissimo che questi dati questo odio
questa negatività serve per far
aumentare il fatturato e se c'è da
scegliere fra negatività nella
popolazione che aumenta e fatturato che
aumenta vince il fatturato
il risultato è che quando si tratta di
fare negatività si usano i social
network si usano questi canali queste
tecnologie per
influenzarci Cosa fanno i social network
hanno una cosa che si chiama
programmatica advertising in sintesi
significa che ciascuno di noi vede delle
pubblicità differenti basate su quelli
che sono i nostri gusti i nostri
orientamenti politici sessuali religiosi
e questa è una cosa che nessun altro
mezzo di comunicazione può fare è un
enorme vantaggio che i social network
hanno su tutti media tradizionali questa
pubblicità personalizzata ci permette di
esplorare un altro confine permette dei
piccoli imprenditori di creare un altro
tipo di fake news che prima non esisteva
permette di creare i piccoli
imprenditori delle fandonie
vi sarà capitato di vedere una notizia
sui social network su vari siti e di
condividerlo con i vostri amici e notate
che arriva da fonti differenti ci sono
due o tre fonti che ne parlano molto
spesso quelle fonti apparentemente
differenti sono legate alla stessa
azienda Questo è un caso sviluppato da
un collega David Puente che ha osservato
che c'erano galassie di mini siti legati
a uno stesso editore che diffondevano le
stesse fake news non perché ci fosse un
progetto ideologico non perché ci fosse
un governo dietro queste attività ma
semplicemente per soldi
fare le fake news oggi ha un mercato
nuovo in questa situazione i giornalisti
quelli che dovrebbero in teoria aiutarci
a distinguere il vero dal falso a
informarsi correttamente sono stati
travolti completamente il giornalismo
online
ha un grossissimo problema è diventato
dipendente da quella pubblicità da quel
programmatica advertising il risultato è
che c'è un fenomeno nuovo Anche qui un
altro confine che si sposta una cosa che
non avremmo mai pensato di vedere sui
giornali notizie scritte male Questo è
un esempio tratto da un giornale molto
conosciuto come mai esce un articolo
scritto così male semplicemente perché è
importante essere primi
se tu ritardi di 20 secondi 30 secondi
la pubblicazione del tuo pezzo la
pubblicità online finirà al concorrente
che è uscito prima Questo è il mondo in
cui oggi si muove il giornalismo e c'è
quindi un corto circuito le fake news
non sono come molti pensano colpa di
internet non sono colpa soltanto di
Internet sono colpa di un processo e in
questo processo i giornali leggono
quello che c'è su internet lo pubblicano
sui quotidiani lo leggono al
telegiornale e Noi finiamo in mezzo a
questo vortice
perché in questo vortice Siamo coinvolti
anche noi come attori noi condividiamo
ci arrabbiamo ridiamo indigniamo ci
indigniamo condividiamo foto di gattini
Partecipiamo a questo mondo di continuo
informazione e molto spesso senza
renderci conto che ci sono delle
trappole ne Cito giusto una noi tutti
tendiamo a credere a quello che vorremmo
che fosse vero non a quello che è vero
provateci la prossima volta Andate a
vedere un post fatto da un vostro amico
Se conferma la vostra visione del mondo
probabilmente lo condividerete senza
chiedervi se sia vero se sia falso Se
invece va contro quella vostra visione
del mondo qualunque essa sia sarete
molto scettici questa è una cosa che
dobbiamo ribaltare
caso pratico Questa è teoria questi sono
dati scientifici molto interessanti Ma
quanto è realmente difficile fabbricare
una fake news ho provato con i miei
colleghi a creare un caso abbiamo dovuto
rispettare dei paletti etici molto
stretti come giornalisti ma siamo
riusciti a fare una cosa Quanto costa
fabbricare una fake news e farla uscire
su un giornale abbiamo creato
un'inserzione su un argomento che dalle
mie parti Io abito in Svizzera è molto
caldo quello dei Lavoratori che arrivano
dall'estero e abbiamo comprato i like
abbiamo speso circa 50 euro abbiamo
gonfiato questo posto su un social
network finché è arrivato all'attenzione
di una giornalista all'interno di una
redazione che ha detto ecco questo
conferma la mia visione del mondo ci
credo automaticamente lo pubblico sul
giornale
a quel punto la gente ha detto Ma è
scritto sul giornale deve essere vero
Chi legge quel giornale e ha quella
visione del mondo se la vede confermata
Questo è il meccanismo delle fake news
conoscerlo È assolutamente fondamentale
Dove stiamo andando in questa corsa
continua alla disinformazione sembra una
situazione difficile da superare Ma si
può si possono fare tante cose
La prima è rendersi conto che oggi
abbiamo un nuovo attore
l'intelligenza artificiale questa
intelligenza artificiale ci impone una
nuova regola non possiamo più fidarci di
quello che vediamo non basta una foto
condivisa da un amico oggi è possibile
con il software creare delle immagini
assolutamente realistiche soltanto la
nostra conoscenza del mondo ci permette
di capire che il papa probabilmente non
si vestirebbe in questo modo
viviamo in un mondo nel quale le
redazioni che per mestiere per soldi
fabbricano fake news Hanno già
cominciato a utilizzare l'intelligenza
artificiale
recentissimo rapporto in cui si mostra
Come già esistono centinaia di siti
molti dei quali in lingua italiana che
fabbricano notizie completamente false
perché all'interno di quelle notizie c'è
uno spazio pubblicitario che voi ci
crediate o no se riuscite se riescono a
farvi leggere quella notizia a non
incasso
Questo è un dato fondamentale per una
delle soluzioni di per sopravvivere
abbiamo dei giornalisti abbiamo delle
redazioni soprattutto degli editori che
stanno cominciando a dire da me i
giornalisti non servono possiamo
generare gli articoli che ho
l'intelligenza artificiale come in
questo esempio prendi un testo prendi
una notizia la riscrivi la fai
riscrivere a un software di chat di
intelligenza artificiale e hai un
articolo nuovo lo pubblichi fine A cosa
servono i giornalisti esattamente a
questo punto molte redazioni Stanno
cominciando a porsi questa domanda
perché vogliono ridurre i costi ma è
molto molto pericoloso perché c'è un
fenomeno nell'intelligenza artificiale
che si chiama allucinazione
significa che l'intelligenza artificiale
che voi consultate attraverso una chat
non sa cos'è la realtà non conosce cos'è
vero cosa è falso e inventa molto spesso
mente racconta storie che non esistono
dobbiamo essere molto consapevoli di
questo fenomeno delle allucinazioni non
dobbiamo cadere nella trappola che io
vedo sempre più diffusa di utilizzare i
vari servizi online di intelligenza
artificiale come oracoli per farci
spiegare come funziona il mondo per
creare un compito a casa per informarci
non funziona così non sono un servizio
informazioni
quello che ci serve Quindi è un passo
avanti l'intelligenza artificiale è uno
strumento estremamente potente nei due
sensi il passo avanti consiste
nell'utilizzare
coscientemente consapevolmente questa
intelligenza artificiale Come fanno per
esempio i miei colleghi utilizzano
questi software per tirare fuori più
rapidamente le notizie false e
comunicarle al pubblico più rapidamente
più efficientemente quindi
l'intelligenza artificiale Può essere
utilizzata anche per il bene non è
necessariamente il nemico
quel nemico quelle fake news quella
disinformazione dobbiamo conoscerla
vi Ho illustrato alcuni dei meccanismi
poco conosciuti dietro questo mondo e
spero che questo possa darvi un'idea di
cosa si può fare per contrastarlo se
conosci questi meccanismi sai
difendertene E questo è il primo passo
ma non c'è solo quello abbiamo delle
risorse pratiche concrete abbiamo delle
Armi In questa lotta la disinformazione
alle fake news sulla quale si basano
tutte le nostre preoccupazioni i
cambiamenti climatici le scelte
politiche Tutto dipende da come veniamo
informati abbiamo degli strumenti che ci
permettono di valutare le informazioni
Ci sono tantissimi strumenti su internet
molti gratuiti che permettono di sapere
se una foto è vera o è falsa Quando è
stata pubblicata se un articolo ci dice
i dati reali
ci sono degli esperti si chiamano
fatshaker che pubblicano attraverso i
loro siti liberamente consultabili
verifiche di dichiarazioni di
informazioni di notizie abbiamo degli
alleati potenti Abbiamo anche delle
tecnologie che ci possono aiutare una si
chiama adblocker significa in sostanza
installare sul proprio telefonino
computer tablet un'applicazione che
blocca i siti blocca la pubblicità per
essere precisi dei siti che fanno
disinformazione e lascia passare la
pubblicità dei siti che fanno buone
informazioni premiamo chi ci informa
bene puniamo chi invece fa
disinformazione si può fare
c'è un'ultima cosa se tutto questo vi
sembra troppo complicato troppo
impegnativo troppo faticoso lo capisco è
vero Può succedere ma c'è un passo uno
che Vi propongo ed è quello di cambiare
una singola abitudine quella che abbiamo
tutti che è quella quando vediamo una
cosa che ci fa arrabbiare o ci fa
sorridere ci indigna o ci preoccupa la
condividiamo
perché ci crediamo molto non sappiamo se
è vero se facciamo ci crea un sentimento
Molto forte quello che invece dobbiamo
fare è ribaltare questa abitudine se c'è
un'arma che ci può aiutare nella lotta
contro le fake news è proprio questa Se
vedi una cosa e non hai il tempo di
verificarla profondamente non
condividerla Non fare quello che fanno
quasi tutti cioè Prendila la mandi ai
tuoi amici la prendi la mandi ai tuoi
amici dice ma non so se è vero Sei falsa
Vedete un po' voi Dobbiamo resistere a
questo istinto fortissimo la lotta la
fake news il contrasto alle fake news si
può fare si può fare tutti insieme e
questi sono alcuni degli strumenti che
possiamo cominciare a usare sin da
subito per cominciare a fare i primi
passi
verso questa nuova società di
informazione più serena più corretta
meno negativa Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]